if you are comfortable someplace you're
probably in the wrong place
comfortable
is bad
because it leads to contentment you're
not trying there's no effort whenever
you stop failing
you're done
they contract me and pay me i don't care
about the money to come back to the
prison i used to hold me
and i worked it freeing people
here's my call
so i want to bring hope
to everybody
all right believe nation i have a very
special guest with me here today in
arizona mr andre norman author of the
new book ambassador of hope now if you
don't know andre this is one of the
nicest humans that i've ever met in my
life and there's a lot of people who
will do nice things for you if you ask
them and then there's someone like andre
who will not only
do the nice thing and doesn't need to be
reminded to do the nice thing but then
he'll remind you
as a follow-up that hey is there
anything else i can do for you
i checked my taxes andre hey how else
can i be of service hey how are we doing
how can i help and
um it's honestly inspirational i super
appreciate that man um in in seeing how
nice you are and karen you are and you
know hopeful you are
you'd think this guy must have had the
perfect childhood and the perfect
upbringing and like the perfect parents
and the of course right of course even
to beaver exactly and then you read a
story and he goes from being in a poor
neighborhood and getting into trouble
all the time and joining gangs and going
to prison and spending
uh having a hundred year sentence on his
head and maximum security and then being
the the king of
of the prison
not guards but the what the prisons the
what third ranking gang member in the
state it's king of the gangs in the
prison
to then having
just a life-changing moment and saying
i'm basically the king of nowhere
and this isn't going to get me anywhere
and just changing your whole life around
and and then getting out on parole and
then serving people and finding your why
and spreading hope and
uh becoming a harvard fellow and
recognized by the ui and is like just
what a life change
and
i guess the easiest place to start with
this is because the book is called
ambassador hope and you are the
ambassador of hope
how do people get more hope
people get more hope when
generally the person is depressed
they're down they're stuck they're in
whatever route they are in they need
somebody to see that
whether the person who can actually help
them or refer them to help
and oftentimes
people will see somebody who's having a
problem or issue and they'll contact me
andre my sister she's depressed andre my
son is suicidal andre
my brother he's on drugs there's people
make a formal request to me they'll say
andre we need this help people who know
me they're in the network call a friend
call a friend i get a call i go
there's that then there's other times
when it came to you you didn't ask me
anything
for me
knowing is the request
if i know somebody needs help to me
that's equivalent to a request
so if i see somebody in need
i don't need
usually if you're in trouble when you're
in need or you're stressing you don't
have the capacity to ask for help
so where i come from what i was taught
knowing
is the request if you know now i have to
make a decision am i going to help that
person or not so if i hear your
situation anybody's situation where they
need help i inten instantaneously ask
myself
am i going to help that person i make a
conscious decision to say yes or no
so you said you know where i come from
what i was taught so who taught you that
i was taught by a guy named natan
schaefer
the ton shafer in the book is an
orthodox george rabbi
there was a guy getting bullied one day
in prison he was i hate bullies i used
to be really short don't look like it
now but i hate bullies so i stopped the
kids from bullying the guy and he
thanked me then he would say hi to me
all the time and so i was like okay
whatever he said he had no idea who i
was or why status in prison he just
thanked me for helping him
and then fast forward probably like two
months later i'm walking in the program
building i saw him sitting down i said
let me go say hi to bob he always says
hi to me so i went in and said hi to bob
baba introduced me to the guy he's
sitting with natan
i know he's a rabbi they know what
orthodox jewish by man didn't recognize
it the feeling nothing he was just a
super cool human
and he had a good vibe or energy as we
call it and i said what are you doing he
said studying i said i studied with you
he said yes i started going in the time
service every wednesday
and for the first month i didn't know it
was a jewish service i just know i was
studying with natan until somebody told
me i was in jewish services i didn't
know but natan taught me accountability
respect
servanthood
caring gratitude forgiveness he for the
most part taught me how to be human i'm
curious how you got the identity shift
to stick so
you had this identity of being
being the head of the gang
third no no
that was not the head i was one of the
bosses but i was not the guy
that'd be dominic williams
but okay so number three but like any
but even your whole upbringing in
in
getting leadership positions i guess in
different gangs and leading people and
getting feeling the power and respect
that comes with that
to then
shift in your identity to be the guy
who's here to serve and help like a lot
of people have this moment where they
feel like i want to i want to change my
life i don't like where i'm going but it
doesn't stick it doesn't stick
because it's an identity thing and and
you
made it stick
so people have hit the bottom of the
barrel but then they hit it again they
hit it again they hit it again and that
identity doesn't doesn't stick around
how did you make that identity stick one
of the biggest things i attributed to
when i had my identity shift i was in
solitary confinement so i'm locked in a
cell 24 hours a day by myself
for the most part and when i decided
that i wanted to be a successful person
and go to harvard university
i was for the most part locked in a cell
by myself so when i started the truck
i was literally there was nobody around
me that could tell me no
or could stop me so i had like a six
month head stop if i had to deal with
people so i'm six months into the
process of trying to be the harvard
person
before i had had i been in general
population and i had the epiphany
overnight and i came out in the morning
the guys were like yo let's go we're
going to sell drugs hey we're going to
beat this guy up you're stuck in the
middle of what you're in the middle of
because i was removed and in solitary
confinement that was my blessing because
i had the opportunity to actually
marinate and sit on it and start to trek
and had
to be nobody i have to be andre
i'd have to be andre the invincible i
don't have to be the boss i was just a
guy sitting to sell by myself
so they put you in solitary to punish
you and it ended up being the thing that
saved you safe literally because i was
in there for two and a half and i
finally woke up that last six months i
got a running head start so when i
finally did come back to population gp
i'm already six months in i got my ged
already i started going to counseling i
started doing all the things to get me
started i had a six and this kept going
how do you not think you're crazy when
you say you're sitting here in solitary
confinement
in a prison i'm gonna go to harvard how
does that not immediately then say but
all of your story and your past and
where you came from and that doesn't
hold you back i sat in the cell when i
had my epiphany realized i was the king
of nowhere i said
i don't want to be here this is a waste
being in prison stupid and there's way
more prisons than just a penitentiary
people are locked in relationships bad
jobs all kinds of stuff my prison was
actually the penitentiary and i realized
i didn't want to be there i said i want
to be free
easy thing i want to be free i want to
be away from him i went away from her i
want a different job that's the easy
part then i looked around at all the
guys white black spanish guys working
the church guys work in the kitchen the
guys who work in the yard the smart guys
the chess plays the ball plays i looked
at everybody
everybody went home everybody came back
not one group got free and stayed free
so i said free doesn't work
i don't want what doesn't work
so i said okay well what's next who
doesn't come to prison
successful people i said so if i can
become successful i won't come here
i said well where do successful people
come from college
so i said i just need to go home and go
to college and i won't have to come back
here
i picked harvard because it's the only
school i knew the name of
okay that's i'm from boston it's down i
just ride my escape one day when i was a
kid so i didn't pick harvard because it
was harvard
it was literally the only school i'd
ever heard of
that's branding on their part
so many people end up in solitary and
they don't have this moment
i had my moment and when i went out and
i told my friends or you called gang
members yo i figured it out i'm gonna go
home and go to harvard they wanted to
laugh at me right but i had a habit of
stabbing people okay so only you got
away with laughing
then they try to talk me out of it
oh dre you can't go you're black you're
a gang member you're in the hole trying
to kill people you're a psychopath they
told me all the reasons i couldn't go
and
what they were really saying is don't
leave us
what they were really saying is misery
loves company
hey let's go beat up somebody they're
down hey let's go stab somebody they're
down hey let's go do this they're down
anything negative that would ruin our
lives they were all unfavorable
if i wanted to start a ride they'd ride
with me in a minute i wanna go beat
somebody up they route me with me i
wanna go kill somebody they're down
the moment i said i wanna go fix my life
they're like
you can't do that
they believe in a system
of casting with this is the way they
belong
and i didn't believe that
there's a lot of cool sections in the
book and we'll read a couple and uh just
get your take on it because i found it
interesting as i was pouring through
so page 63 talk about doubling down you
say it was in my nature to be the best
at whatever i decided to do therefore it
was if i was ever going to be a f-up i
was going to be the best f-up ever
and what was interesting is
there's so many people who've got so
many talents like you you you got all
these leadership positions
and you had drive and ambition like i'm
gonna go be the best right but just
point it in the wrong direction complete
wrong direction
right so a lot of times just hey let's
take our skills and abilities and
ambitions that just shift the direction
and go forward
how do you if somebody feels stuck or
lost or doesn't have hope
how do they identify
some of those characteristics or traits
or skills that could point them in a
different direction environment is huge
but the seeds that are planted that you
were even bigger my mother used to tell
me boy if you take 10 of your energy and
point it to something good you turn this
world upside down i just never listened
i stayed where i felt comfortable
if you are comfortable someplace you're
probably in the wrong place
either in a nursing home about to leave
this planet or you're in the wrong place
so
comfortable
is bad
because it leads to contentment you're
not trying there's no effort so it
doesn't matter where you are if you are
comfortable you're not being challenged
you're not being pushed you're not
having bad days you're not fit if you
whenever you stop failing
you're done
so if you don't have hope the person
that says look at your environment are
you an environment that's challenging
you do you have a goal that's
challenging you you have people around
you that are pushing you or you have
people around you they're pulling you
and just doing a complete assessment
and then when i came up my goal of going
to harvard
and nobody believed me
i looked in the mirror i said what's
inside of me
this stopping this from happening
because all too often i would go to my
friends when i first got the epiphany to
go i went to my friends and they shot it
now i went to my mom she shot it down my
grandmother even shot it down
and
we go to people who don't have the
vision or the hope that we want and we
get reinforced with what we don't want
so there is somebody
who will reinforce your goal it may not
be your friend group so i had a ged
teacher who i didn't know
came down i told her my goal she said
that's a great goal andre you know why
she's a teacher you know teachers do
they encourage
know what friends do that concerns
themselves what they're where they are
teacher encourage chaplain the the rabbi
encouraged i got people who are
encouragers around me and started
talking to them versus just my friend
group if somebody feels stuck how do
they find the thing inside them that
they're good at something
that they have a skill they have a
talent it's just again maybe pointing in
the wrong direction how do we find that
thing forget the skill and talent what
i'm doing now
is very little coalition between what i
thought of when i was sitting in that
cell what i said was not setting that
cell was i want to be successful
i had no definition had no plan or
structure to that but i knew if i could
become successful it's going to put me
in the right spaces and places around
the right people if i'm heading for
success i'm not going to be hanging out
with certain types of people doing
certain types of things certain types of
temptations so i just get a goal in a
sense if i want to be successful i want
to be healthy so i want to be healthy
i'm on a health kick right now so i'm
not eating vegan i'm not eating all the
rest of the stuff i'm just eating better
than i was before my worst days are now
let's bump those up there's great days i
eat wonderful stuff then this is like
horrible stuff we had a speaker
yesterday said hey this eliminate the
low days
so i'm eliminating my low days and i'm
at break even or better the rest of the
day so don't try to figure out i'm going
to be a doctor i'm going to be a lawyer
i'm going to be a psychiatrist no i just
want to be in a better space and
identify a location and head towards
well to your point about environment
mattering you also traveled with your
trainer yes he's here helping push you
and doing your workouts and making sure
you stay on track because for years i'm
going to work on my health
i'm never i'm literally on the road
every day so my phone rings i fly to
baltimore my flow rings i fly to london
my phone rings is somebody someplace
with a relative in crisis
every day
so whether it's
professionals or regular folks my phone
rings come help
so i go
i was coming here from i went to boston
i got called to go to new york
i got left new york went to richmond i
was supposed to go from richmond home to
change my bags i gotta try to go to
baltimore then i had to ship half my
clothes home so i can fly to phoenix
i haven't touched home in about a week
and a half so my trainer would have been
sitting home for a week and a half
talking about where's andre he's doing
crisis management he's saving people's
lives
so i finally came to the conclusion of
it's so much easier to have him fly with
me
because i'll never be home
simple solution but it took about a year
and a half to get to it and so for
people who will resonate with the story
like yeah my friends don't support me
they're
they're they want to stay comfortable
they're not happy they're negative but
they don't they don't know who to turn
to they don't have a teacher they don't
have a rabbi like how do we find some
person who can help inspire us or give
us hope one of the reasons that made me
reach out to you when i say do i help
this person i say no a lot
i don't say yes to everybody
even though you don't know i'm sitting
home and i'm watching i think we wanna
on a on a meeting one time you mentioned
your circumstance
i hear this everybody mentions their
circumstances and every single time i
heard a circumstance i said yes or no if
i'm going to step in or not
one of the things that made me say yes
is hey you're a giver
b you're super humble be you're super
giving out great vibes on your channel
and in life every day i've never seen
you not try to help somebody
so these are the things that i saw
when i saw you
and how do you not help that person
i teach people
be the thing you want people to be for
you
if you want a mentor are you mentoring
somebody you want a coach are you
coaching somebody you want to make money
are you giving money to other people it
can't just be a one-sided thing because
if i'm just giving to you and you're a
stop gap then it's dead in the water
i wasn't a church guy i'm walking
through a prison one day i walked up to
a door and it was like a bible study
going on
for some reason i stood outside the door
i'm trying to find somebody and the
pastor
chaplain's in the room preaching the
bible study
never forget this he said be a vessel
in this instance let it pour into you
then you pour it into somebody else
it wasn't a church thing it was a lesson
be a vessel and of all the places all
that stuck with me i don't know why but
it did
so when i see people who are vessels i
have no problem pouring into you because
i know you're going to pour it into
somebody else
and my goal is to help people so if it's
directly or indirectly it's all the same
who would you pick as some of your
heroes right now my heroes oh we
ingenious network joe polish is a
different hero that's a brother to me
joe polish met me at a down point in my
life
i was
restarting
trying to find my way
he met me he heard about the work that i
did he said to me andre
what do you need to live
i told him he says i'll pay your bills
for the next five months
met me five minutes in
no story i didn't even actually i didn't
ask for a dime he just said i'll pay
your bills for the next five months
and four and a half years later we're
still together
because we didn't connect on business or
marketing or advertising we both love
helping people
and i know
if you gave him an option of either
helping people or business you choose
help people
so that's where we connect we don't do
any business together we don't have any
deals together the only deal we got is
james recovery and when somebody calls
and need help we go
so hero i'm natan schaefer
still in my life
still in my life i gotta i collect
mentors i can list off every mentor the
best man in my wedding was a was a
prison volunteer pat dempsey um deacon
john mcmillan was one of the guys at my
programs that was helping me out tim
allen the day i came home i met tim
allen and he started studying with me
mentoring me and helping me out tim
allen's a mentor i can ken marin
i go down a list and then dominic
williams and will dunn these are two
guys i've been working with friends and
brothers with for 20 plus years i've
been following domiground since i was
12.
i met will and i came home the second
day we've been together ever since
my favorite sister imani my other two
sisters get mad when i say that but
she's my favorite sister it is what it
is
um my son is a mentor to me
he's living a life that i always wanted
he goes to a great school he skis in
switzerland he goes on wonderful trips
he's getting good grades he's going to
go to stanford or columbia
that's so encouraging to me not just as
a dad
but as a person
and
mentors can be older younger different
genders it doesn't matter
so i have probably
ben richter
um john ratliff
howard getzen
um ben hardy dan sullivan and babs i go
down a list
of michael and rosalind i mean from here
and from around the world i mean i just
have so many people
who've poured into me that i'm a sum
total of them
and
their belief in me stops me
from ever going backwards
i've got my st louis team
it's in the book but
keith alpha
john rulin john o'leary russia keeley
and my brother i'm saying dave spence
they came and got me when i fell off my
cliff those five men came and got me
i love he said you collect mentors one
of the things i share with my aunts a
lot is
i like to collect good people
it's just you find somebody that they've
got a good vibe about them just
collect them like find a way to hang out
with them find a way to stay stay in
touch even if it feels weird you meet
somebody in the event and and for all
the names that you just list listed off
if somebody's watching that may sound
like well now he's got so many people
but it was one by one oh definitely it
wasn't just like you got out of prison
and like hey here's his job i walked out
of prison
and it was like i met tim allen when i
first came home he was the first guy i
met on the other side of the wall tim
allen
and we just used to sit together he was
a pastor
we would sit together and he would just
talk to me once a week
i'd go to his office i talked to the
kids at juvenile and he worked in the
juvenile building and i'll go to his
office we'd just sit and talk
and that was it there was no formalized
anything i was he was always welcoming
doors open i just had to walk in
and
my sister susie spence oh first i met
susie she said we're gonna do great
things and me and her and her husband
and others turned the whole school
district around then we came back um
with dan curran and we turned ferguson
around when ferguson rise happened me
dan curran and susie actually did that
work we went into the streets of
ferguson at two o'clock in the morning
it's like a little white guy from st
louis but he cared
i'm saying the mentor thing andre all
your mentors are black almost none of
them are black i'm pro-black every day
of the week but a mentor to me is
somebody who cares has capacity has
character has consistency and that you
can believe it if you happen to have the
same color as me cool but if you don't
i'm not going to turn my back on a great
mentor just because you know you know
the same color as me
i love it okay let's do another reading
got some got some some good stuff in
here okay
this one i love so chapter six page 99
so many people wake up and say i'm not
going to drink anymore they wake up and
say i'm not going to use drugs anymore
they're not going to gamble anymore
they're not going to cheat on their
taxes anymore they say it definitively
as though speaking it into existence
will make it happen
but willpower alone doesn't work
ben hardy
shout out to ben willpower doesn't work
if that's the case i'd be 210 pounds if
i could just say it you actually have to
develop the habits develop the routine
develop a system be an ecosystem an
environment that supports it or at least
prison and support my goals but if you
can put yourself in a positive ecosystem
that helps
there are things you have to tangibly do
on a daily basis to be successful
you can't write yourself one letter you
can't give yourself one affirmation and
it happens it's an ongoing daily
struggle to be
great and the question is
not can you do the ongoing daily
struggle but do you really want to be
great
i can sit here and say
i'm literally there's 20 million people
hypothetical number from 1980 to today
who've been released from prison
i would put my resume next to any of
them and would hands down shatter them
if it was a contest
because i came out not to be number 2000
not number 3 000 not number 4 million i
came out to be number one
i know in canada yeah i don't push like
that it's american trait i want to be
number one and i would stand with my
resume
next to any man or woman who've been
released from american prison the last
40 years
and say i shattered him because it's a
competitive it's a competitive thing but
i compete with me
i'm actually competing against anybody
else i'm competing with me can i be
better than yesterday can i be better
than last time i've been doing suicide
interventions
for 20-plus years i haven't lost anybody
with andre sitting in
solitary
if you were to go back and look at him
now like would he say yeah i'm going to
go do that
this wasn't the plan yeah this was
when i first came home from prison i
work with black kids only because it's
why i felt comfortable like i said if
you're comfortable you're not growing
then i got challenged to work with black
boys then i got a chance to work with
girls which was i don't know anything
about being a girl i went to work with
girls they had a horrendous storyline
domestic violence molestation is is just
horrible prostitution crazy then i got a
challenge to go work with white kids
like i don't know why kids got
everything why do i need to go help
white kids i help kids who are getting
shot kids who are parents of smoking
crack kids who are living in war-torn
cities why am i going to suburbs with
white kids
but then i went and white kids drank
smoke got bullies cut cut up
same problems we have this in a bigger
school
then i got challenged to go work with
businessmen i'm like why am i going to
work ypo young president's organization
in eo why am i going to work with these
white businessmen they got everything no
they drink they smoke they cheat on
their wives they're stressed out they
cheat on their taxes and i got to the
point where i said no longer will i
judge somebody based on my ignorance i
just show up
but in the beginning
my goal was i stay where i'm comfortable
then i grow from that it was okay for me
to only work with black boys in the
beginning because it's was comfortable
but when i got that down then the next
challenge came and i accepted it i got
the girls down the next challenge came
white kids and i accepted the next
challenge came i ended up going to
guatemala and helping kids in guatemala
costa rica honduras saudi arabia sweden
if there's people over the world who
need help
and if we think in terms of our town or
our tribe
then you're shortchanging yourself and
you're denying so many people that's a
great section in the book where you
first get challenged to go and help
the white kids instead of just sticking
to your community and then realizing oh
my gosh
i mean they're just human too and
everybody needs help and the crazy thing
was my rabbi
my mentor all the people who were my
mentors in prison for the most part the
outsiders are all white so when i got
asked to go help white kids i was like
no i'm not doing that doesn't make sense
i've been getting help from white people
for like 10 years now but i couldn't see
in the because i was comfortable where i
was and i didn't see the
the craziness of saying i'm not going to
go these could be their kids and how can
i not go but again
we go with what we know
until we're challenged and then you have
to accept your challenge you're going to
be challenged to grow
you're going to be challenged to expand
and you have to do i did an interview
two months ago i'm in new york lady
comes in she sits down
she says hi my name is jane and my
pronouns are she they
i'm like okay um what does that mean
i whole interview turned into her
explained to me
the queer world pronouns and everything
goes cause i legitimately didn't know
and the same thing like white folks when
george floyd died they didn't know black
folks had a that bad day my phone rang
off the hook after george floyd died all
my white friends wanted to know how they
could be helpful how did they miss it
what could they do different whether it
was a company or a personal individual
and i'm sitting here with this lady and
she's explaining this whole world to me
i know what i can call
i i'm just clueless about i hear the
labels and the tags i'm clueless i'm not
in that community so i felt i believe
the same way white folks what about
black folks when they got introduced to
a reality
and i asked you a question
i believe
we've been waiting 400 years
to have the race conversation
when george floyd died it opened the
door and the phone started ringing i
told all my black friends answer the
phone
answer the damn phone
answer these people's questions
we've been waiting 400 years for this
conversation get off pride get off any
answer the damn phone and answer these
people's questions so we can finally get
to reconciliation and healing
what were some of the
more surprising and more powerful
questions
it wasn't so much it was like we didn't
know
that black light because when you
watched george floyd die
it was during the pandemic the entire
world was watching at the same time it's
not a rodney king when you saw it on
tape delay or you saw it on the news and
they could take it down with social
media everything was right now the whole
world saw the same thing at the same
time and was shocked
and they were like okay this is just so
wrong but now who do i ask and who would
i process this with
if you're white in utah or montana or
new york or l.a you don't have
you feel funny about calling your black
friends to have this conversation
my friends called me i said well dre
does this for a living he helps people
and they started calling me have
people's kids call me crying
well i had no idea it was like this and
you saw the world from this vantage
point that every day you walk out your
door
it's a concept of you might die or your
son goes out the door you're worried
about he might get pulled over and die
and that's a reality for where we live
and where we come from
and they just want to know how can we
help how can we support what can we do
what is the right thing to do they got
this thing on tuesday we post a black
picture on our instagram is that enough
do we say what do we say how do we do it
and what has walked him through how do
you actually make a difference
how do you impact people and be
sensitive
you don't have to know everything
but how do you be sensitive to what's
going on
and you think it's had enough of a
ripple effect
i believe more people need to pick up
the phone
and call and more people need to answer
the calls
there's power in division you're you're
feeling bad right now because you you've
been humbled or exposed or shown that
you didn't know something i have a
choice as a black male as a person who
on the other side with the answer i can
hold the answer over your head
i can give you the answer and let you be
free
there's two ways to teach independence
or codependence
holding it over your head is is
codependence now you're dependent on me
because i'm going to keep playing games
with this little thing
i can give it to you just let you be
free i don't believe in teaching for
codependents i want everybody to be
independent person on their own
and i just believe
in anything else people see
opportunities i saw an opportunity to
heal someone else's opportunity to
exploit
and that's just how the world works
so going back to the willpower you know
was not enough to make the change
what what was the most consistent habit
that you were doing to remind yourself
that this is possible for you
the more i just kept my goal and kept my
one goal of harvard university in my
forefront
um that's it so when i got my ged i
didn't quit
when i started going to college in
prison i didn't quit i graduated anger
management i didn't quit when i got a
job working at harvard indirectly like
speaking on the campus i didn't quit
when i got we started working with the
white house i didn't quit when i became
the top-rated speaker at ypo i didn't
quit when i joined eo i didn't quit when
i called me to 30 different countries i
didn't quit
then in 2016 dr charles overthree called
me
and he awarded me a fellowship
then i was in trouble because i hadn't
had to go for it but
then
25 years
from the day i said it
is to when it happened
and i had so many achievements and
accomplishments along the way i could
have i tapped out i did great by any
measure i've done great
but again i'm not competing against you
i know what i said to myself in that
cell
i wanted to be at harvard i didn't say i
want to be at the white house they said
i want to be at london business school
didn't say i want to be in australia
saudi arabia i said harvard and i'm not
backing down off that
and when i got there
it was like one great when i got my
email a normal harvard.edu and i got my
little desk a little plaque i'm on fire
because it took 25 years
but that was my goal
the hardest part was achieving it and i
had to find another goal right
that was the hardest thing
because it kept me focused for 25 years
and what's a new goal the new goal
is
mass incarceration there are so many
people locked up
and i say mass incarceration definitely
100 percent the 2.2 million people
incarcerated in america
need to be revisited
and is that the right system or the
right way then i also i accident beyond
that i go to people's houses and help
them free from the prisons that they
live in the prison of alcoholism the
prison of um drugs the prison of you're
saying sex addiction whatever gambling
addiction prison of whatever you're in
i i used to think like i thought black
boys were my calling
freeing people
is my calling so i want to bring hope
to everybody so it's like well dre why
are you ingenious network those people
aren't going to prison no they're in a
different type of prison
so i go from houston to new york to l.a
to san diego to montana i was at a
conference last year
the lady came up to me i came on stage
they paid me to come on stage i got on
stage i looked at the audience i said
they don't want to hear my story i felt
the energy from the crowd i started
talking so how are your kids how are you
doing and people came up to me after my
nephew's suicidal dialed a number i'm
doing calls in the hallway for like the
next four hours then one lady from
montana was like my daughter tried to
kill herself last week i got on a plane
i flew to montana
there was one girl in one town in
montana i spent a day with her
now she's doing wonderful
that was worth the trip i don't need 50
people in the school or
auditorium for 10 000.
everybody counts because i used to be
that one person
and people showed up for me
what i love i mean lots of things to
love but you really unite her
and you see a lot more of the
commonalities and people than the
differences which which i think we need
and you tell this great story in the
book where when people are leaving
prison
everybody's cheering them on whether
you're bloods or crips or whatever
background whatever gang you're in
you're fighting you know in the in the
system but then when you get out
everybody's turning you on because
that's everybody's goal right
and so even if
you do a lot of corporations you do a
lot of work you know speaking now just
beyond
not just a prison system for people who
are trying to be uniters and see the
common element and
cheer for their enemy because they see
you know a human there what advice would
you have
the story you're talking about we're in
prison every day
we fight against the latinos we fight
against the other blacks we fight
against the whites we fight against each
other
every day we're fighting it's like the
non-stop fight
every morning monday through friday at
nine o'clock
they announced the names of people who
are going home
that's evan carmichael john stanley
john roberts bob smith report to the
gate
that means you're leaving we know you're
leaving and when they start announcing
those names
we as prisoners understand somebody's
leaving this place this hellhole
and we in our hearts chair
i might hate your guts but i am so happy
that you're leaving this place
and i'm happy for you for that 10 or 15
seconds
and when they walk out the gate and they
say movement over it's back to normal
we're back we're all still in the hell
hole let's go until tomorrow morning
for that five minutes every morning
everybody's united
what is what i've come to understand is
let's expand that five minutes
let's not try to go the other let's stop
well we're already together
i don't need a gang summit no we need to
expand that five minutes to seven
minutes to 20 minutes how do you expand
what we already have we're trying to do
it in reverse
that's how i see it when i went to
prison i see glitches
is that thing too loose i can make a
knife that cl's not paying attention i
can sneak by him where's a glitch for me
to exploit
now i look for glitches to bring things
together
i went to high school in st louis i
looked for every glitch that didn't
allow a kid to learn then i sealed it
then i started learning
i go into a to a company i look for
every glitch that's allowing something
not to happen that the boss wants then i
seal it i see glitches i see i see the
things you can do to exploit
so i use the same skill set from prison
by using companies now to seal those
holes up that they can't see
and what i love i get back to an early
question is you
you have this ability or skill
just pointing the wrong direction that's
what my mom told me you point it here
you can have amazing impact yeah you've
created an organization it's been
recognized by the u.n it's some
tremendous work
tell us about it
um the academy of hope
it was three and a half years ago there
was a riot in south carolina
and seven men died were murdered and 30
others were wounded the entire prison
system 19 000 people went on lockdown
i know nothing about this because i
don't watch the news the news is just
too negative for me so i don't even
watch it i'm at a conference
and i'm doing my seminar i tell my story
about overcoming prison and being a gang
leader changed my life and the rest of
that
at the end of the conference after my
seminar lady walked up to me she says
that was a great story but can you do it
that's what he talked about she said you
was a gang leader you ran the yards you
was a tough guy and then you changed
your life around can you do it in other
people
i said yeah she said well we have a
situation in south carolina we need you
to come because we had seven dead bodies
and we have 30 people in the hospital
and we need that in our system
my first response was i'm busy
i'm like lady i'm a corporate speaker i
got speeches lined up around the corner
i talk about 10 15 grand 20 grand a pop
i'm like listen i'm not trying to go to
prison ben they've done that
i even set up a bunch of prison programs
when i first came home go see one of my
mentees she said no we need you
and i was like lady i'm busy then she
said where's your commitment to the work
call my assistant brianna cancel
everything we fly to south carolina
and we go inside
and we start talking to men over six
days
ten prisons eight thousand prisoners
come out of itself for the first time in
five and a half months
and they were responsive to the message
because my message wasn't to whites or
the blacks or the spanish or the crips
of the bloods the it was to the people
i speak to people and i spoke to them
the five minutes
the five minutes when we're all together
i came in and i spoke to the five
minutes and everybody identified
that i came back and we set up a program
in that facility it's been running for
almost four years we went from seven
dead bodies to one fistfight
we went from inmates hating staff or not
liking staff to one of the guys in our
program saved the seal's life
he was in the process of being murdered
and one of our guys stepped in and saved
his life when i asked him why he did it
he said
right is right wrong is wrong what i saw
was wrong
oh that's always been his motto we just
expanded
who fit into the right and wrong there
was a time that cos didn't fit into his
right wrong now they do we didn't change
him we just expanded that five minutes
and we included people that weren't
included before
and we've been there four years and it
was almost a year ago
i come from massachusetts reached out to
me
and the commissioner reached out and
said andre come home
and the unit in that book that you hear
me talking about living in going to get
my hamburger all that stuff
i now run that unit
as a contractor they contract me and pay
me i don't care about the money they
come back to the prison they used to
hold me
and i worked it now
and i walk through the hallways that
like him
she got a lot of like you're bringing
him
she said yeah that's what they need to
see
that's hope
we're authority we're possibility we're
we're chances he's hope
when he walks through here he's
literally hoped for them
and to her credit um in massachusetts to
the director's credit in south carolina
um brian strong and carol meji they
wanted hope
they wanted better
for their people and they came to the
point to say well i can't deliver hope
they can deliver on programs classes
better better food but it is they can't
deliver hope
hope comes from inside
and
i've had countless commissioners and
directors of corrections and sheriffs
say we want hope and your presence is
that
so for me it's like super humbling i get
to be that guy you've done so much to
help people
either in this video spread more hope or
to people who've actually touched
individually
if they were to hold you in their
prayers tonight
what would you have them pray for
for me
one i get my health together
real talk need better help
health is wealth
and i need to be healthy
more healthy than i am and i am doing
better but i'm not done i've set a goal
the same way i said i won't go to
harvard i set a goal 225 pounds i'm in
it's it's fixed to the wall and it's
non-negotiable
and it's not hopefully going to take me
25 years to get there i don't have 25
years
i work every day
for men and women around the world to do
and be better so right now i work with a
company out of texas they have tablets
in prison so i collect trainings and
poems and music and i put them on the
tablets for the guys and girls in jail
genius network has donated so many books
to prisoners because inside we get the
worst of the worst books the worst the
worst trainings we just get left over
so
genius is like here's the best books
from the best authors from the top
editors from the top
thinkers so they're going in with the
dan sullivan's our book club is called
the sean stevenson book club
because when he passed i was so hurt and
i i didn't want his name to die so we
have a book club and every day at any
prison i work in for one hour a day we
stop everything and we read and dan
sullivan sean stevenson joe polish i'm
saying um ben hardy
jason fladlin and mike koenig we're
reading everybody jim duke everybody's
keith cunningham dean jackson we have
the best of the best
chris foss they love i got a prison full
of criminals and everything never split
the difference by chris foss and they
loved it because it's not about prison
prisoner fbi it's lessons
where people and their lessons
we got rid of the titles
of criminals prisoners bad people and we
go with the lessons
so if they could do anything for me
i would love
to um have more content that i could
then go down to secures and go to jpeg
platform and just i want to give them
the best of the best
information because we have 2.2 million
people in jail i want to change their
lives
and i can't do it by myself i don't know
everything so somebody's out there as a
specialist and whatever area i don't
care if you do pottery if you fix cars
i'm saying you fly i don't care what you
do somebody in jail loves what you love
and i want them to have access to that
i love it the man is andre norman this
is his book ambassador of hope go check
it out we'll link it up in the
description below
andre appreciate you man oh man always
to see my recent one-on-one with les
brown check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe i'll see you there
whatever you see yourself doing now
you're marching
toward purpose
meaning
and impact